hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well we don't have a
full fledged theory of justice you know
totally spelled out with Epicurus as we
do with many other philosophers in part
because we only possess a few of his
works in the present out of the many
works that he wrote but we do have some
important discussions of justice
primarily occurring in his principle
doctrines towards the end of them but
with a few other remarks scattered here
and there in the corpus and he's going
to deal with essentially two main topics
the nature of justice what is justice
and then because of the way he
understands justice we also have to
think about the usefulness of justice
and why is justice useful how does
usefulness fit in with us and if we're
thinking about this in terms of Epicurus
as being a hedonist philosopher as being
you know one of the art main articulate
errs but hedonist theory then you might
say well why isn't he talking directly
about pains and pleasures we're gonna
see that he will talk a little bit about
pain but why isn't he focused on justice
as a maximizing pleasure and minimizing
pain or something like that why talk
about usefulness well you know one
reason is because unlike many of the
other
Virtue's or states of character justice
actually doesn't focus in the ancient
world of these primarily on pain and
pleasure it is understood as something
that has a value in its own right or
that has some sort of usefulness on the
sort of profitable nough some sort of
beneficial status for other things like
you know you might say well it's good
for society or it's good for getting
things done and Epicurus does indeed
have a view on justice very much like
that so let's start with in a question
what is justice now he tells us this is
a very radical position there never was
and by extension there never is or will
be anything like absolute justice
justice per se justice in a simple way
that applies across the board to
everybody instead what we find he says
is natural justice that is justice that
is arising within human communities
within human beings that are that are
natural creatures it's an expression of
usefulness he says it's an expression or
a symbol of usefulness
now usefulness for what well primarily
for preventing people from harming other
people or from being harmed so there's
already a kind of reciprocity in there
you can talk about justice within say a
friendship or within a family or within
a military troop you can also talk about
it as within a whole society as well and
Epicurus has all these sorts of things
in mind so this is the primary purpose
of justice justice understood in a sort
of broad sense it is something that is
useful for keeping the peace keeping us
from harming each other keeping us from
being harmed by other people there's a
kind of trade-off there so he says he
goes so far as to say that justice
really depends on a kind of agreement so
many people have seen in Epicurus a
early formulation of what's called
social calm
tract theory we're either in an explicit
way or in some sort of implicit way
people get together within a society and
they say look how can we actually live
together how can we keep ourselves from
being harmed from each other given that
you know we have tendencies to do things
that we know are right to steal to lie
to cheat to injure I'll make an
agreement with you and you make an
agreement with me not to do these sorts
of things and then we'll have to have
some sort of authority who can actually
enforce this rule or perhaps will
enforce the rule there's a lot of
different variations on this and that
the curious doesn't worry too much about
which particular variation we're going
to have but you just say it stems from a
mutual agreement with fellow human
beings in society not to harm each other
not to do things that are going to
create problems for each other he also
goes so far as to say that it varies by
application in laws of specific
communities so what is just in one
community it is enshrined in the laws
there may not in fact be just in another
community or even in the laws there
there could be laws that if you go from
one community to another community seem
to contradict each other and for
epicures it's not a problem because
there isn't any single standard of
justice across the board that gives you
laws you know in a strict sense that
says this must be the case in all cases
you won't find some regularities if you
don't have some way of regulating
violence who is allowed to use violence
in what situations who's allowed to use
deadly force well then you're going to
have you know a lot of people harming
each other there is almost always some
rules about sexuality who is allowed to
do what with whom there's almost always
laws about property but the exact laws
the specifics of them are going to vary
from community to community depending on
what they actually find useful and what
may be useful in one time in one culture
in one set of circumstances may not
actually be useful later on so Epicurus
is quite alright with
the notion of revising laws it's not as
if once you make a contract with
everybody if there isn't even a contract
you just as agreement that you stuck
with it once you know once and for all
time you know you you can't change it at
all Epicurus says no is over here with
the usefulness part when the laws cease
to be useful they don't express justice
anymore
that is the purpose of the laws to
express them to articulate and to give
us some guidance about what is actually
just but it's going to be particularized
to the community to which one belongs so
if you're moving from one community to
another if you're moving say from
Corinth to Rome you know that old
expression When in Rome do as the Romans
do Epicurus would say exactly right if
the Romans have some laws and there are
good laws on the books about something
that the Corinthians you know the Romans
forbid something that the Corinthians
allow well if you're in Rome then to be
just means to follow those those rules
not because simply law is is you know
good in and of itself but because law
enshrines this mutual agreement that
keeps us from harming each other so that
leads to this question of usefulness why
is justice useful why is it something
that is beneficial to us yeah there's
three main things that Epicurus talk so
I'm actually going to start with this
bottom one here since we began with
thinking about Society so there's four
I'm sorry he says when the laws are no
longer useful
the laws are no longer just they no
longer express justice this shouldn't be
a surprise to us he thinks if we get
upset about this sort of thing we say
look the law back in 1789 was against
this and look at people are doing that
now we can we can say well is it
actually harming anyone for them to do
that activity now maybe the people back
then were you know somehow harmed by it
but we're not anymore so
we can take that law off the books now
why is justice useful in a personal
sense here we start getting to questions
of pleasure and pain and the freedom
from pain that constitutes a certain
kind of pleasure so
Epicurus says justice provides pleasure
and it prevents pain it really doesn't
provide much pleasure in and of itself
you might think of it as sort of
facilitating the conditions under which
pleasure can occur but it certainly does
prevent pain now it prevents pain in in
multiple ways right
in one way it keeps other people from
harming us so we can live securely with
other people and it keeps us from doing
that too if we abide by the rules so
that's important if we want to enjoy a
good life we need some sort of norms
governing them that we can live
according to that aren't you know to
oppress in it or to owner us but which
we can say yeah that makes sense we
should go along with that I know that my
feelings might make me go this way but
the law says this so I'm gonna follow
the law we count on other people doing
the same thing so justice keeps us from
being harmed right
Epicurus also says and this might be a
bit more debatable if we think about say
sociopaths right the person who violates
the norms of justice the agreement
always has to feel fear or worry about
being detected and he's not just
concerned about justice in terms of the
legal system he's also a like in the
Vatican sayings he says look don't do
anything that you would be ashamed of
your neighbors finding out if you know I
came to light that's also the same sort
of thing if you're doing the wrong thing
and you know that it's the wrong thing
and maybe you say well it's to my
advantage to do it or you know I'm
come by a desire I'm kind of a greedy
guy so I so I take stuff that I'm not
supposed to take or you know when my
neighbors lend me stuff I don't return
it to them or I return it to them in a
bad condition well if you do that
Epicurus thinks that you're going to
have a bad conscience and that by itself
from a hedonist perspective is a bad
thing because having a band or a guilty
conscience means you're worried about
people finding out and you're also
worried if it's like legal justice about
punishment or I suppose if it's personal
interactions about some sort of reprisal
or or shunning or something like that so
there's there's you know two sides to
this there's the don't commit injustice
because then you're gonna be on the outs
with everybody else and that will be
painful for you
and do also commit justice do you follow
the norms of justice precisely because
you're hoping other people will do that
and when we all do that we have a
relatively pain-free existence so that's
where the usefulness of justice really
lies her for Epicurus and that's what
grounds the whole conception of justice
so when he's saying a person cannot live
pleasantly without living prudently well
and justly this is what he means by
living justly and this is why he is
saying that